it's official we finally know when we
can pre-order the m2 macbook air and
when it will start arriving but with
that some people are saying that the m2
macbook air is going to be disappointing
just like the recycled m2 macbook pro
well in this video i will be sharing my
opinions on this machine with you who
should buy it and who should avoid it
along with an updated buyer's guide with
all of the knowledge that we have gained
testing and comparing the m2 macbook pro
to give you guys the best information on
which one you should order and which
specs you should upgrade now right out
of the gate i have to say that i am
extremely excited for this machine now
yes it is not going to be ground
breaking in performance it will be
slower than the m2 macbook pro which was
already a bit disappointing with certain
configurations compared to what was
advertised and what we expected now with
that said this is a brand new redesign
it's an extremely thin machine just
looking online at videos doesn't do it
justice and it has lots of nice creature
comfort upgrades that will make this
machine last and be enjoyable for many
years to come i think that the average
person that buys one of these is going
to absolutely love it compared to their
previous intel mac or their windows
machine and it will make a lot of people
happy now with that said if this machine
is starting to push your budget buying
it for 1200 bucks and then adding on the
upgrades that i'm going to strongly
suggest i would say take a look at the
m1 macbook air the performance of those
machines are amazing and you can pick
one up for about 800 bucks refurbished
on amazon we've seen them as low as 850
dollars for brand new ones with full
warranties
and it will do everything you need maybe
even better than the m2 macbook air now
how in the world can i say that well two
reasons the first one is the ssd
situation we found in our testing that
the base ssd
was at times half the speed of the m1s
and that it can make a real world
difference even for tasks that are not
that difficult now it's not because you
need an extremely fast ssd you're not
constantly transferring files but when
you open up different web browsing tabs
say google drive maybe youtube video and
some other things and you open up an
application
you do run out of memory because
remember macos needs four to five
gigabytes by itself and you only have
eight and that's when the ssd is used as
ram and that is when the m1 ended up
being faster than the m2 now with that
we have to talk about thermal throttling
we know that the m1 slowed down from
three gigahertz down to 2.9 2.8 and all
the way down i believe to like 2.2 or
2.3 because it doesn't have a fan now
with this machine we are hoping that
apple put in maybe a bigger heat
spreader or possibly some other kind of
cooling like vapor chamber but based on
the information that we've gotten
recently for example there was an
interview with mkbhd apple is
reiterating that the m2 pro is the one
that you need for consistent high
performance meaning that they most
likely didn't do any better cooling and
on top of that this machine is extremely
thin it's a 20
reduction overall
and that doesn't help for heat and with
that we found that the m2 chip
used about 33 percent more power in
order to get 13 percent more performance
so when we combine all of those things
the chances that the m2 chip will
perform much better over the m1
it just isn't very realistic now that is
not a horrible thing it has better
single core performance has better
memory bandwidth and for the tasks that
most people do it will do a great job so
counting in the redesign the better
webcam the speakers the fast charging
that updated display you will be very
happy with it but don't think that you
should get the m2 macbook air for better
performance now let's get into the
updated buyers guide the first thing i
would suggest is to upgrade that ssd
most likely we're still going to see a
single nand chip just like the m2
macbook pro
and because of that if you also have
eight gigs of ram
well then you can get slower performance
than the m1 macbook air now some
youtubers are now saying well sure you
did find that it does make a difference
in the real world but most people won't
even notice that and that might be true
but just because you don't notice that
something is worse than the previous
generation that doesn't make it okay at
least in our opinion things should get
better not worse by upgrading the ssd
you will not have slower ram swap than
the previous generation now if you
really don't need the storage in that
case spend a little bit more money and
go for the 16 gig ram option the m2 chip
is a really nice chip by itself but it
does need extra ram or normal fast ssds
to work its best for example when we
exported 50 42 megapixel images it did
that in about two minutes slightly
faster than the m1 but with that when we
tested out the 512 gig model with no
other applications no web browsing open
just lightroom it took a minute and 45
seconds so that's a 12 and a half
percent improvement or 15 depending how
you do the math
just by getting a larger ssd option but
switching to 16 gigs of ram that took a
minute and seven seconds we've never
seen
that big of an improvement just by
having a higher amount of ram it is
incredible so that m2 chip really needs
to be unlocked and apple should have
gave us either more ssd or more ram at
the base price for these machines with
this m2 chip so do yourself a favor if
you're going to do productivity of any
sort custom order one and get 16 gigs
and 512 if you can afford it that will
make a huge difference for productivity
much more so than before and for those
that ask why why would i recommend that
where with the m1 i recommended getting
the 8 gig well now we are being a lot
more limited by the ssds in the ram
compared to the m1 and compared to intel
chips way more so when the cpu and gpu
itself is limitation you don't start
feeling that difference for ram and ssd
i mean we do super deep dive testing in
this but when the chip is so good that
it needs to be fed needs to be fed
faster and with a bigger amount of
storage and
the ram amount well you see massive
improvements now as far as upgrading to
the better gpu option i would not
recommend doing that we know we're going
to be thermally throttled apple has said
that themselves they showed it off on
their charts so upgrading to extra cores
that will then be slowed down more so
because of thermal limitations i don't
think it makes sense to do that so there
you guys go we are going to be able to
order this on friday this this friday
here in a day and a half and then on the
15th is when it's going to be coming out
we cannot wait to get ours we're
ordering multiple options to be
comparing them we'll see the performance
compared to the m1 so if you guys want
to wait for that before ordering you
guys can definitely do that and then
you'll be able to see what the very best
option is and how much the differences
in upgrades will infect your specific
workload not just in general thank you
guys for watching this has been max
click that circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there and i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
you